de l'assemblée nationale mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
madame la maire de paris mesdames
messieurs les ambassadeurs
monsieur le président du mémorial
mesdames messieurs les anciens déportés
le 27 janvier
est une date à jamais gravé dans la
mémoire de l'humanité
il y à 70 ans
le 27 janvier 1945
vers 15h
les armées soviétiques ouvre les portes
du camp d'auschwitz birkenau
c'était la révélation de leurs oeufs
ce n'est pas encore une libération
car la plupart des survivants avaient
été emmenés par les nazis dans une
longue marche
la marche de la mort
épuisés de faim de froid de maladie ils
vivaient leurs derniers martyrs dans les
plaines glacées de silésie
ainsi les grossman avait pu écrire dans
son enfer n'avait rien vu de si atroce
vous vous l'avez vécu
le monde lui découvrait
l'extermination méthodique
programme et
scientifiques des juifs
un crime qui n'avait pas de nom
tellement il était ignoble alors un
nouveau mot fut créée pour le désigner
la shoah
le plus grand crime jamais connu et
jamais commis dans l'humanité il fut
perpétré
en terre d'europe
par le régime d'une des nations les plus
civilisés de notre continent et il
trouva des alliés des complices
jusqu'ici en france sous le gouvernement
de vichy
ce crime fut est unique par son ampleur
6 millions de femmes et d'hommes
exterminés parce que juifs
et combien d'autres mis en esclavage
mise à mort parce que disent ils gagnent
homosexuels slave communiste résistants
handicapés
6 millions
parmi lesquels un million et demi
d'enfants
trois quarts des juifs d'europe plus du
tiers de la population juive dans le
monde
ce crime fut unique par sa méthode
bureaucratique
industriels
les nazis avaient fait de la solution
finale comme il l'appelait un problème
qu'il leur fallait régler par tous
moyens
d'abord dressé des listes
avec des millions de noms
pour que l'on sache qui était les juifs
comment les retrouver
et pourtant laissé aucun de côté
puis
les nazis sont allés pas tout seul
d'ailleurs
les chercher
les ont raflé
embarqué
entassés dans des wagons à bestiaux
puis les ont conduits vers les chambres
à gaz
voilà ce qui s'est passé en plein 20e
siècle voilà ce qui fût
ce crime fut unique aussi par sa nature
il s'agissait de détruire les preuves
que l'assassinât était été commis par
balles comme en ukraine
par camion à gaz comme un chêne l'eau ou
dans des camps d'extermination
comment aux chouettes
les mêmes précautions fut reprise par
les nazis il s'agissait de maquiller
l'horreur
pour qu'elle soit menée jusqu'à son
terme pour qu'elle soit définitive tous
les juifs
devaient mourir
il ne devait plus rien rester de leur
présence
les cadavres étaient brûlés comme au
moyen âge lors des grandes épidémies
les cendres dispersées pour qu'il ne
reste aucune trace de l'abomination
il s'agissait d' exclure les juifs de la
société des humains pour les faire
disparaître du passé du présent
et de l'avenir
et pour que soit rendu
impossible le travail de deuil pour les
éventuels survivants
robert badinter et voit que l' attente
désespérée du retour de son père
et l'absence de résignation à sa
disparition
bruno bettelheim ajoute
que pour lui le deuil fut impossible
puisque certains sont revenus pourquoi
mes parents à moi
ne reviendrait-il pas un jour telle
était sa question
ils ne sont jamais revenus
mais ici au mémorial de la shoah leur
nom figure pour toujours
ils n'étaient plus que cendres et fumées
ils retrouvent grâce à vous une place
dans l'éternité de la pierre et vous
mesdames et messieurs
vous vous êtes les derniers témoins
infatigable
inconsolable
intraitable et vous continuez de nous
dire ce qui fut il y à soixante dix ans
je veux ici vous exprimer toute ma
reconnaissance
toute la gratitude de la nation
pour
le travail le mot est mal choisi pour le
devoir que vous vous êtes infligé un de
plus pour témoigner pour dire pour
raconter vous parcourez les villes et
les écoles de france vous fait même
encore et j'imagine
ce que ça représente comme souffrances
le voyage vers auschwitz sur les lieux
mêmes où vous fûtes déportés vous voulez
montrer l'enfer à ceux qui ignorent
qu'il a existé sur cette terre et que
vous l'avez connu
c'est simone veil qui dit que les
déportés ne sont jamais sortis des camps
que leurs esprits y est resté et que la
shoah continue de hanter leurs vies
et leurs nuits alors vous avez décidé de
faire de votre cauchemar une leçon
une leçon pour les autres vous êtes le
visage de l'humanité
le beau visage
celle que
les bourreaux voulait supplicié cette
humanité et c'est pourquoi
les côtes de votre voix ne doit pas
faiblir
parce que sinon comme le disait et loire
nous périrons
je sais ce qui vous tourmentent
qui parlera
des cornes qui parlera de la shoah quand
vous ne serez plus là
je vous fait cette promesse qui est un
engagement la république française
n'oubliera jamais
et avec les documents les témoignages
que vous nous laissez les livres les
textes les enregistrements et ce lieu
qui est le vôtre
alors nous n'oublierons jamais
le mémorial de la shoah monsieur le
président est issu du centre de
documentation juive contemporaine dans
la création à grenoble dans la
clandestinité en avril 43 fut en tant
que tel un acte de résistance
isaksson son fondateur avait décidé en
pleine occupation de rassembler les
premières archives de ce qu'ont signé
les écrits
d'accumuler des preuves pour qu'un jour
la souffrance se transforme en mémoire
puis la mémoire en histoire en 1956 le
centre s'installent ici dans le marais
ce quartier du coeur de paris
qui avait été pour les juifs du début du
siècle un refuge
avant de devenir dans les années 40 un
piège là où
on est allé vous cherchez il y à 70 ans
le
pire a été commis il fallait donc qu'il
y ait un mémorial
le 25 janvier 2005 le président jacques
chirac l'inaugurer avec ce mur dédié aux
75 mille 721 juifs qui furent déportés
de france avec la complicité active de
l'état français il avait commencé son
discours jacques chirac par ces mots
tirés de la bible hébraïque
souviens-toi
n'oublie jamais
21 septembre 2012 j'ai moi-même inauguré
le mémorial de la shoah de 36 36 cette
ville dont d'où partaient les trains
vers auschwitz
j'étais entouré de jeunes venus des
écoles de la seine saint denis à qui
j'ai lancé le même appel ne jamais
oublier
car ce serait insulter ceux qui sont
morts dans les camps
aujourd'hui le mémorial et je veux ont
félicité toute l'équipe
a pu rassembler 40 millions de documents
accueille deux cent mille visiteurs
chaque année
et organisé d'ailleurs une fois par an à
l'occasion de yom choix la cérémonie de
lecture publique des noms de tous les
déportés juifs français
cette cérémonie dure 24 heures
et en 24 heures il n'est pas possible de
lire même la moitié des noms de ces
innocents supplicié
le mémorial est dédiée à la transmission
c'est à dire un lieu où
il est expliqué autant qu'il est
possible analyse et autant que
nécessaire le mal et le poursuivre même
ce mal dans ses moindres replis
le mémorial c'est un lieu de vigilance
de clairvoyance
on apprend que la mémoire est un
engagement
un engagement contre toutes les haines
car le mémorial
commémore la shoah mais aussi tous les
génocides
le 20e anniversaire du génocide des
tutsi au rwanda
et cette année il célébrera
l'anniversaire du génocide des arméniens
ce mémorial porte la douleur la vôtre
celle des survivants mais elle porte
aussi la responsabilité des vivants il
exige donc le mémorial le dépassement
pour conjurer l'effacement d'effacement
qui serait le dernier crime des
bourreaux
avec cette interrogation terrible qui
nous étreint encore aujourd'hui
comment après la shoah
comme ans après
ce crime contre l'humanité cette
ignominie qui poussent à la haine
raciste de certains jusqu'à
l'extermination de leurs semblables
comment l'antisémitisme peut-il encore
ressurgir telle est la question qui nous
est une fois encore posée
pourquoi les juifs ont ils le sentiment
que jamais ils n'auront de repos ni de
répit
peggy écrivait c'était 40 ans avant la
shoah
depuis cinq ans tchèques les juifs
vivent trempé dans la douleur
ils vivent encore aujourd'hui dans la
douleur
j'entends l'appel de ceux qui me
demandent nous demande quand cette
malédiction finira
il y a trois semaines à paris
quatre hommes sont morts dans un magasin
casher
pour le même motif
qu ont été raflés les familles du vel
d'hiv en 1942
qui ont été frappés les fidèles de la
rue copernic en 1980 qui ont été
assassinés les promeneurs de la rue des
rosiers en 1982 qui a été torturé le
jeune ilan halimi en 2006 qu été
massacrés les enfants de l'école aux as
tu auras de toulouse en 2012 parce
qu'ils étaient juifs
ils sont morts non pour ce qu'ils
avaient fait
mais pour ce qu'ils étaient des juifs
et ils sont encore quatre noms qui
doivent s'ajouter à ceux si nombreux
inscrits sur ce mur de la mémoire
la montée des actes antisémites et
depuis plusieurs années une réalité
insupportable
leur nombre aurait doublé l'année
dernière
agression
incivilités
vandalisme
ce fléau conduis je le sais
certains juifs à s'interroger sur leur
présence en france
la france à laquelle ils ont donné tout
leur coeur
et dont ils ont ressenti profondément au
cours de leur vie
les joies et les tristesses
7 france qui les aime
comme elle aime tous les enfants de la
république
mais cette france où parfois ils ne se
sentent plus en sécurité
et ce doute cette interrogation est une
blessure
une blessure terrible pour la république
qu'elle doit soigner qu'elle doit
traiter
vous français de confession juive
votre place est ici chez vous
la france est votre patrie vous lui avez
donné votre talent
votre travail
votre courage et parfois votre son
notre pays ne serait plus la france
s'il devait vivre sans vous
et si le terrorisme vous conduisez à
vous éloigner de la terre de france
de la langue française de la culture
française de la république française qui
émancipe et les juifs alors le
terrorisme aurait atteint son but
la responsabilité des autorités de la
république
elles sont ici présentes tout rassembler
et donc de tout faire pour que les juifs
soient pleinement chez eux en france
pour que jamais il n'y s'y sentent
menacés ou isolées
pour combattre un ennemi
il faut d'abord le connaître et le
nommer
l'antisémitisme il a changé de visage
mais il n'a pas perdu ses racines
millénaires
certains de ces ressorts n'ont pas
changé hélas dans la nuit des temps
c'est toujours le complot le soupçon la
falsification
mais aujourd'hui il se nourrit aussi de
la haine d'israël
il importe les conflits du moyen-orient
il établit de façon abjecte
la consulta bilité des juifs dans le
malheur des peuples
il entretient les théories du complot
qui se diffusent sans limite théorie du
complot qui ont dans le passé
conduit déjà au pire
alors face à ces menaces
il nous faut des réponses des réponses
fortes des réponses adaptées
la première c'est la sécurité
le gouvernement de manuel valls a pris
les dispositions qui convenait pour que
les synagogues les commerces des écoles
les centres culturels de la communauté
juive soient protégés il ya même eu une
présence de militaires pour assurer
cette protection mais je sais aussi
l'amertume et la colère que cette
présence inspire à beaucoup d'entre vous
comment en 2015
comment
accepter qu'il faille des soldats en
armes pour défendre les juifs de france
c'est nécessaire et nous le faisons et
nous le ferons aussi longtemps que ce
sera demandée je veux aller plus loin en
améliorant la visibilité et l'efficacité
des sanctions
ce qui supposera de généraliser la
caractérisation racistes et antisémites
comme circonstance aggravante d'un délit
et sortir la répression de la parole
raciste et anti sémitisme du droit de la
presse pour l'intégrer au droit pénal
général et pour que la sanction soit
l'occasion d'une prise de conscience des
peines
alternatives à valeur pédagogique
exemplaires seront prononcées
la deuxième réponse c'est la
transmission
c'est la connaissance
c'est le rôle de l'école
je veux redire ma confiance à l'égard
des professeurs des enseignants de notre
pays il faut leur travail
nous devrons les aider
à le mener à bien et partager avec eux
pour les traiter
les inquiétudes qu'il respire que leur
inspirent les événements récents comment
des élèves ont-ils pu le 9 janvier
dernier briser l'unité du recueillement
c'est une nouvelle alerte parmi d'autres
elle nous oblige l'un des instruments
pour désamorcer cette ignorance c'est
l'enseignement de l'histoire de la shoah
elle est au programme de l'école du cm2
de la troisième de la première elle doit
pouvoir être enseigner sans aucune
restriction
il ya aussi un certain nombre
d'événements qu'il nous faut renouveler
le concours national de la résistance et
de la déportation
donc je remettrai les prix le 8 mai
prochain à l'occasion des cérémonies du
70e anniversaire de la défaite du
nazisme
ce prix ce concours existe depuis 1961
il doit être
renouvelée rénové et je souhaite qu'il
puisse y avoir une mission qu'ils soient
conduites pour en assurer la pérennité
le mémorial doit prendre aussi tout
sympa
il accueille près de 2000 groupe
d'élèves du primaire du collège et du
lycée
et je sais qu'aujourd'hui il y à des
élèves qui travaillent sur la shoah dans
la préparation précisément du concours
de la résistance la transmission la
connaissance le savoir
que rien ne soit laissé dans l'ombre
pire que rien ne puisse être interprété
la troisième réponse c'est de prendre
conscience que les thèses complotistes
prennent leur diffusion par internet et
les réseaux sociaux
or nous devons nous souvenir que c'est
d'abord par le verbe que s'est préparé
de l'extermination nous devons agir au
niveau européen et même internationale
pour qu un cadre juridique puisse être
défini et que les plateformes internet
qui gère les réseaux sociaux soient
mises devant leurs responsabilités
que des sanctions soient prononcées en
cas de manquement
l'union des anciens déportés l'union des
étudiants juifs de france
lance aujourd'hui même un appel contre
le négationnisme sur internet
il s'adresse aux grands opérateurs nous
les connaissons
ils ne peuvent plus fermer les yeux ou
alors ils seront considérés comme
complices de ceux qui se diffuse
la france soutiendra cet appel et cet
après midi je serai à auch witz et je
demanderai aux représentants des
gouvernements qui sont présents de s'y
joindre également
à partir de ces principes
sécurité
transmission régulation du numérique je
souhaite que le gouvernement
présente d'ici la fin du mois de février
un plan global de lutte contre le
racisme et d'antisémitisme
le 11 janvier dernier
après ce qui s'était produit dans notre
pays
cet attentat sur trois jours qui a
touché des journalistes d'abord des
policiers ensuite des juifs enfin nous
étions des millions à témoigner que la
france se tenait droite face à ceux qui
voulaient la faire plier il avait des
dirigeants venus du monde entier qui a
testé avec nous que la france
lorsqu'elle était agressé n'était jamais
seul
notre réponse
ce fut la fierté
la dignité
et l'unité
nous sommes à proximité de l'allée des
justes qui longe ce mémorial est le son
des justes ce n'est pas simplement le
courage
c'est la lucidité
et c'est la responsabilité là d'imiter
toutes ces valeurs
que la france a porté
le son des justes c'est qu'il existe
toujours une autre voie que celle de
hurler avec la meute
ou de rester indifférent la leçon des
justes c'est que l'individu même seul
n'est pas sans pouvoir n'est pas sans
devoir
le message des justes il est beau il est
fort
ce sont les femmes et les hommes qui
font le monde tel qu'il est
et qui peuvent donc le changer
elles ne sont des justes c'est que la
france avance quand elle et rassembler
autour de ses valeurs
rassemblés
unis
n'empêche pas les différences est sont
légitimes
n'écarte pas la diversité elle est
salutaire le débat démocratique
il est nécessaire mais au-delà de tout
il y à la république une et indivisible
alors à tous nos concitoyens à vous à
vous qui êtes les témoins je veux vous
dire que la france
protégera
protégera tous ses enfants qu'elle ne
tolérera aucune insulte aucun outrage
aucune profanation ça vaut pour tous les
cultes ça vaut pour toutes les
convictions toutes les consciences je
salue ici les représentants de l'islam
de france qui se joignent à nous
les actes anti musulmans se sont
également multipliés ces dernières
semaines
et chaque fois que
une femme un homme un enfant est victime
d'une agression pour ce qu'il pense ou
ce qui suit à quoi ils croient c'est une
atteinte à ce que notre pays peut
représenter aux yeux du monde
ensemble nous sommes la france
celle de la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen qui a proclamé à
la face du monde nul peut être inquiété
pour ses opinions même religieuses
et la libre communication des pensées et
des opinions est un des droits les plus
précieux de l'homme
les nations démocratiques
ont fait le choix d'inscrire le 27
janvier
dans la mémoire de l'humanité
quand elle voulu dire
que le 27 janvier c'est un événement
universel qui ne concerne pas que les
juifs
mais qui concerne le monde entier
nations ont voulu aussi rappeler à tous
les peuples ou conduisait l'intolérance
et qu'elle pouvait les frapper tous
ces fraudes fans le philosophe
anticolonialiste y eut cette phrase
quand vous entendez dire du mal des
juifs
dresser l'oreille
on parle de vous
la mémoire des crimes contre l'humanité
n'appartient à personne
elle est notre héritage commun
pour comprendre la barbarie vous vous
l'avez vu en face
il faut savoir la reconnaître partout où
elle est et ceux qui prétendent nier une
souffrance
au nom d'une autre souffrance
ne sont jamais du côté des victimes
mais toujours avec les bourreaux
dont l'un des ses plus beaux livres
patrick modiano
le prix nobel de littérature
ce livre qu'il avait dédié à dora bruder
jeune fille disparue dans donné dans la
nuit des quand il écrivait ceci
il faut longtemps très longtemps
pour que ressurgisse à la lumière ce qui
a été effacé
c'est cette lumière que vous nous
redonner ici au mémorial vous les
anciens déportés vous les témoins vous
aussi des acteurs de la transmission
et c'est cette lumière que nous devons
porter tous ensemble contre les nuits
qui menace qui menacent encore qui
menacent ici qui menacent partout mais
nous sommes là vive la république et
vive la france